hey you guys it's my flickers of fear
movie review show and it's the second
movie of what i'm calling folk horror
february as i mentioned on the last
couple of shows uh some months this year
i decided i was going to do more of a
theme just to make things easier like
for me to pick movies uh because i have
such a big list and sometimes it's hard
to like sort out which ones i want to do
so this month uh in celebration of the
recent documentary that uh shutter just
added which is all about folk horror i
decided that it was a genre i wanted to
get more into because there's like a
bunch of other uh folk horror movies
that i wanted to talk about and i
thought this was as good a time as any
now the one that we're talking about
today this one is kind of an anomaly
actually because i kind of feel like
this is called eyes of fire it came out
1983. i think it has an alternate title
cry blue sky although i don't think i've
ever seen it called that
this is a movie that seemed like for a
long time
sort of
slipped under the radar and i think that
for years and years it was almost like
one of those movies that sometimes like
if you saw it on vhs like back in the
old days um and then it just kind of
went out of print and everyone sort of
forgot about it and it then it seems
like recently it's gone through a little
bit of a revival i guess as i said
because in the last few years folk
horror is kind of you know with the
witch and midsummer and things like that
so i kind of feel like people are
getting more interested in folklore as a
genre so you know this one's sort of
gotten like rediscovered a little bit
now interestingly i actually didn't know
this when i watched the uh the
documentary on shutter
but
severan films i believe has just put out
this massive limited edition box set
that has um like 20 different folk
horror movies it has like a big book it
has the documentary that's also on
shutter and it just has like all these
kind of more obscure folk horror movies
from around the world and izafire is one
of the ones that's on there and shutter
also added like a handful of you know a
selection that was also in this box set
which is how i got interested in it
because i said now this is really
interesting because this is a movie it's
an american film but i had never
actually heard of it like when i looked
at the title
i thought to myself well
i might have seen that cover at the
video store at some point but for
whatever reason i just never
rented it maybe i thought it wasn't
scary enough or it wasn't i don't really
know like what the reason would have
been because i rented most horror movies
back then but i do kind of feel like in
the 80s i was more into like slasher
type stuff so this is definitely not a
slasher so
it's maybe uh that's why i never ended
up watching it but this is kind of an
interesting film so it has actually been
released uh you know restored and
released but for a long time
all you could get and i don't even think
like the movie came out in 83 and i
don't even think the vhs came out until
87
and then it was out for a few years and
then it sort of went into print like out
of print and then it didn't even get put
out on blu-ray until just of like a
month ago seriously i think it was yeah
like early december 2021 so yeah so this
is kind of like a movie that really you
know you didn't even you couldn't even
see it for a long time except on like
shitty vhs or like you know foreign
transfers and things like that but it
has been restored now and it looks
really uh nice
so this movie is uh an american folk
horror movie which you don't really see
a lot of
so it's a period piece it's set in 1750
uh you know kind of in i guess it's in
like the northeast pennsylvania or
somewhere like that type of area like
prior to the revolutionary war
so uh there's a lot of kind of stuff
about uh shawnee indians there's a lot
of kind of stuff about uh scots irish
immigrants to the area that are bringing
kind of their own
uh european folk magic to it so it's all
that kind of stuff now i will say
even though if you're into folk horror i
think this is definitely worth watching
but there are some kind of things about
it that i don't that i didn't love but
it's still like a fascinating
movie i didn't really read a lot about
it prior to
watching it because i was just kind of
curious to see what was going to happen
with it i knew that it was set in 1750
and that it was about these you know
these settlers that like went in the
woods and like bad [ __ ] ensued that was
like pretty much it uh but it yeah it's
like a really interesting they don't
really i was gonna say they don't make
movies like this anymore they didn't
make movies like this back then either
and it's like really really hard to
put my finger on i don't know it's just
a strange strange movie like the pacing
is kind of strange
and
i don't know but i found it like really
interesting i really liked the lore
behind it and actually the monster
design in it like the monster uh looked
pretty cool so uh so this was directed
by a guy named avery krauts
now i think that this is one of only
three feature films that he directed uh
he did one later on i can't remember
what was called but it was like a drama
and it had karen black in it but i think
he's primarily more like a photographer
uh you know he's from kentucky i think
so he didn't really do a lot of movies
so as i said this one kind of like
slipped under the radar
so what you have at the outset this it's
almost kind of like it's
i don't know it's like a wraparound
story but the whole thing is like told
in flashback i don't know if it
necessarily needed to be but it is uh so
at the very beginning
there's this uh encampment of french
soldiers and they find this young woman
maybe late teens early 20s and this
little girl their names are fanny and
meg
and they're basically like and they're
apparently like the only survivors of
whatever this tragedy was that happened
so the french soldiers are trying to get
out of them you know what happened to
you where your parents you know where
the rest of the people you were
traveling with and they then like tell
the story because they're basically like
well
leah saved us they say uh leah's the
queen of the forest she saved us with
magic and all this other stuff so that's
kind of like uh setting up so then we go
back to see what happened to these two
girls how they ended up here so as i
said this is set in 1750 they don't
really say specifically where but i'm
assuming because it's shawnee uh an
indian tribe that it's somewhere around
pennsylvania maybe ohio somewhere like
that uh you know that's because i you
know the tribe is uh algonquin uh that's
the language they spoke and that's
generally where their territory was so
i'm assuming it's somewhere around there
so uh what happens at the very beginning
uh we're at this t we're in this town
and apparently there's this preacher
this new preacher who has come there
named will smythe
and will smythe
despite being a preacher is a little bit
of a poonhound gonna say so he's taken
up with this woman named eloise
in the town who is actually the wife of
this dude named marion dalton who is a
trapper and he's gone for long periods
of time so i'm assuming like she got
lonely and uh you know needed some
needed some d so uh she kind of like
took up with the preacher now the
preacher also has this other woman
living in his house it's not clear
i wasn't real clear maybe they said this
and i wasn't paying attention but i
wasn't real clear on whether that he was
banging that woman too or whether this
was just like his ward her name is leah
and she's irish and she looks totally
irish too she's got like she's got like
the she's a very very ginger
so uh and she her hair is very big and
uh so i so i don't know they kind of
read her as like insane you know what i
mean uh or kind of i don't know special
insane
now i don't know because he says at some
point that oh i
you know the townspeople were burning
her mom for being a witch but i stepped
in and tried to save her but i couldn't
save her and then i had to like take
over the care of this woman's daughter
and keep the townsfolk from you know
killing her as well as a witch that
turns out to be not entirely true like
that's just kind of the story that he
told so i'm assuming because i think
when i was reading the uh plot synopsis
on wikipedia um it was saying you know
he lives in this house with two women
who he's not married to and blah blah
but i i i took it that leah was like his
ward like he was taking care of her but
i mean i never got the impression that
he was sleeping with her too but maybe i
just missed that i don't know but the
fact that he is taking up with another
man's wife even though that man is gone
all the time uh the townspeople aren't
having it
and they decide that they are going to
hang him and maybe eloise too and also
maybe leah um you know because they
because they think she's weird and she's
like a witch which spoiler alert she is
uh but she's a good one so they tried to
hang him but leah starts like chanting
these weird kind of things and the rope
breaks and then all the townspeople are
like oh bro okay well maybe uh god
intervened or whatever and then the
preacher eloise leah and a few other of
the townsfolk that didn't like uh all
the other townspeople i guess
they decide they're gonna get the [ __ ]
out of dodge and go off on their own and
form their own little community or
whatever uh so they lock all the towns
people
in the barn and then they pretty much
take all their [ __ ] like they take their
boat and like all their supplies and
stuff which seemed like a dick move but
okay but well they did like try to hang
him so i guess he was like a little
bitter about it so they set off on their
own
to find their own garden of eden i'm
assuming this is kind of like a little
breakaway sect
um you know maybe will smythe wants to
go
form a cult somewhere where nobody cares
if he's sleeping with other people's
wives and stuff like that i'm assuming
but he does kind of convince like a few
people to go along with him like a few
couples and some kids and stuff like
that so they kind of set off on their
own
through what is a hostile uh territory
owned by the shawnee indians and also
there's kind of like some french
soldiers in there too and they don't
really cotton to all these uh people
kind of like coming through their
territory and [ __ ]
so they travel for a little while a
couple of them get killed
and then they come to this place
where
smythe is convinced this is where our
garden of eden is gonna be
and uh he figures this out because
there's already like some cabins and
stuff there's always like a little i
don't it's not even
really a village it's just like a few
cabins but they're kind of abandoned and
they're sort of like falling down and
he's like hey you know most of the work
is done and we can just like fix these
up and move into them and god told us
you know it's god's will or whatever
uh but then leah uh wanders off into the
woods and she finds in what is actually
quite a striking image this part of the
woods that's like all the trees and [ __ ]
like that are covered with white
feathers
now uh she comes back to the camp now in
the meantime
eloise the chick that was banging you
know that was married that was banging
the preacher her husband has come back
from his trapping uh you know sojourn
and has come back to the towns to town
and the town people told him hey your
[ __ ] wife like took off with the
preacher and a bunch of other people uh
you know and says where they went so he
follows along and like finds them
so he actually kind of intervenes when
the when the you know little
group of people are going to get killed
by indians and
it kind of it's like two indians and
like
three french guys i think and so they're
gonna get killed but then marian comes
and he intervenes and he can speak
algonquin and various other languages so
he's basically like you know don't hurt
him it's you know and so he tells him a
tale so now it's super awkward because
now her husband is back and you know so
there's kind of like they're at
loggerheads like the husband and the
preacher because obviously
you know there's that whole situation uh
but marion when leah comes back and
she's all covered with white feathers
he's basically like okay well this is
bad we probably shouldn't stay here
because all those white feathers that
means the shawnee indians have put that
there like to warn other people away
from this area because it's cursed or
haunted or whatever um but of course the
preacher is like navs those savages
we're not having that uh this is where
we're supposed to be everything's
already here we're staying
now as time goes on uh they start to
discover that even though in this valley
where they have chosen to settle
uh even though they're safe from the
tribes around there because the tribes
all believe rightly
that the area is haunted
um they do start to see some other kind
of weird upsetting [ __ ] happening in the
sense that you know sometimes they will
look out the window and see what appears
to be muddy naked people like running
around
outside and they kind of go in the woods
and some of the trees have like
anguished looking faces in them
also something really weird turns up too
this little girl who appears to be a
little native american child
turns up at the edge of the village and
is like hey look how cute i am you know
and and the preacher is like oh you know
this is another sign like we're supposed
to raise her as a christian and so they
take her in but leah is not really she
she doesn't really talk until later she
just kind of like she kind of speaks in
tongues
and
you know and kind of like runs around in
the woods like i said she's kind of like
a witch but not in a witch
she's more like a nature sprite kind of
person you know what i mean where she's
running around barefoot like eating mud
and and having visions and stuff so
she's had a vision of this little native
american girl
being essentially like a demon and she's
like red and she has like these big
yellow eyes and [ __ ] like that so she's
like well this is a trap and we've
invaded on something's territory now
what this something is they don't
explain it super clearly but i think i
mean there's one scene where marion is
talking to his daughter fanny like
around the fire and he's been around
he's very familiar with this particular
area like he said he speaks the
languages of the tribes in the area as
well so he kind of has a peace with them
because he's just a trapper and so he
says well this area
what a lot of the local tribes believe
is that every person an animal that is
killed in this area like their blood
seeps into the ground and when enough of
it seeps into the ground it's almost
like it all like gathers together like
into these
beings like nature
elementals i guess maybe would be a good
way of putting it and they're not
necessarily evil they just don't they're
just kind of like nature spirits and
they don't really like you know humans
kind of [ __ ] up their land or like
disrespecting them and stuff so
you know so so they'll come together
into like these essentially elemental
spirits kind of like sprout out of the
ground and will [ __ ] you up if you're on
their land so there's that so i think
that's what all like the naked muddy
people are running around but there is
also this one large being which later on
in the movie they call the devil witch
and i think it's played by a man but i
guess it's supposed to be i don't know
if it's supposed to be a woman i think
it's just supposed to be a monster but
it's just kind of like a big it's
actually pretty cool like the monster
design it's just this big
i mean you can see the face and it's
just like a like a witchy face but it
almost kind of looks like a tree person
kind of but it's like i don't know it's
hard to explain um it kind of reminded
me of okay so imagine if
the bum from behind winky's diner
in mulholland drive was like twice that
size and also kind of looked like a tree
and then you're kind of like getting
what it is so
what that so what this witch is doing
apparently
is trying to like capture the souls of
the settlers and when someone's soul is
captured
it puts them into a tree because their
face will like go into the tree but if
you know that that happens and you go
and
like pull the person out of the tree
then they'll be okay because there's one
scene where
uh apparently like one of like the
little girl the little native american
girl who was maybe a demon
takes one of the other little girls
who's i think it's meg i think or i
can't remember like what the other
little girl's name is but takes one of
the kids into the forest and then they
find the little girl later like hanging
upside down and they think she's dead
because her face is all [ __ ] up but
then like leah or whoever like knows
that you know her soul is now trapped in
the tree so if you go to the tree and
like [ __ ] up that tree or pull the you
know pull her out of the tree then
she'll come back to life so that's what
happens so essentially what what this is
is kind of like a battle between the
elemental spirits that's what i'm going
to call them in this particular
clearing this particular settlement um
who the settlers obviously perceive as
evil because
you know they're trying to kill them uh
and leah who is essentially like a white
witch she's like an irish more like a
fairy i guess she's a person but
she has like magical powers uh like i
said she has she can uh she can see the
future not that far in the future but
she does like have visions and stuff she
can move things like just by thinking
about them so it's essentially like
she's trying to
save the settlers from these elemental
spirits that are like out in the woods
so that's pretty much the story um you
know i don't want to spoil too much of
it if you have shutter you can watch it
on there
it's not a terrific movie i mean
but there's something like really kind
of creepy and intriguing about it i
really do like the monster design a lot
i really like some of the shots like
particularly some of the shots of like
the the elemental spirits presumably
like they're they're all like these
muddy naked people and they're you know
kind of like they'll just appear in the
woods and it's like that's kind of
creepy so there's like a lot of creepy
scenes in it and i really like the lore
behind it i like the idea i really like
the um the imagery of like the faces in
the trees because it looks like real
people which with just like trees like
built around them so that looks really
cool
like i said the witch looks really cool
i will say though that
the acting is very uneven in the sense
that the guy that plays marion dalton i
think is like the best one like he comes
across the best the other acting is kind
of like hit or miss it does seem like
and some of the accents come and go
because i kind of feel like eloise the
woman that was you know the the wife
that was banging the preacher i thought
she was supposed to be irish because at
first she had like a pretty pronounced
irish accent but then as the movie went
on it kind of came and went so there was
that kind of thing and the guy playing
the preacher his accent initially seemed
british but then it kind of like wavered
so i wasn't entirely sure
like i wasn't even entirely sure if they
were even supposed to have accents or if
they just like forgot about him or i
don't know uh so the acting was a little
bit like some of them were better than
others uh the kid actors not fantastic
but you know what he is it wasn't
terrible uh it wasn't like so bad that
it was you know distracting really but
it was kind of like
it was a little bit something that i
noticed uh the special effects
are
cheesy but not bad for 1983 particularly
for
a movie that was presumably this low
budget and as i said uh the monster
design of the quote unquote devil witch
was actually really cool and honestly
there's one shot in particular which i
really dug where the devil witch was
like standing there and then suddenly uh
it's like sucks into the ground like
into the leaves and stuff like that and
it looked really cool they might have
done it reverse i couldn't really tell
but it looked really good like it looked
really fluid like it how it just i'm not
entirely sure how they did it but that
looked really cool um so you know it
does have kind of a lot of those uh kind
of weird flashy like 80s like let's
everything goes negative type of
things like that sometimes you saw like
an 80s music videos and uh you know
where everything's like posterized so it
did have that so it's kind of cheesy but
not any more cheesy than like some other
1983 things and honestly
this i mean considering this was 83 they
didn't really make like i said they
didn't really make a lot of american
folk horror films i feel like a lot of
american folk horror films
were either set somewhere else like set
in europe or they were more like in the
kind of haitian voodoo type of area
which you know is also folk horror so i
don't really you don't really see a lot
of
folk horror films like american folk
horror films set in the pre like during
the colonial period like the
pre-revolutionary war period and i think
that was like a really cool
idea honestly i you know i'm not a huge
fan of remakes but
i would be really interested to see
somebody remake this because it's a
great idea for a story i really really
like uh the kind of lore behind it i
like that it was set in a time period
that you don't see a lot of horror films
set in and i think that was really cool
so i would really like i'd be curious to
see like a modern
filmmaker's take on it particularly
somebody like robert eggers or something
like that who's really into
folk horror
i kind of feel like it would be cool to
see
someone like that
kind of take a whack at this story and
see what they could do with it because
like i said the all the ideas are there
and most of this is like really good the
like i said the pacing is kind of
strange the acting is sort of
you know
not that good like in some cases but
there's still like a really cool like
compelling story in there that you could
really do something with like nowadays
so let me know if you saw this back in
the day i know some people did because i
looked up there's not a huge
number of reviews of this on youtube but
i did find a couple reviews out of guys
who were you know my age or a little bit
younger that had actually seen it on vhs
back in you know the mid to late 80s and
remembered it fondly and uh so some
people did see it back then i did not
like i said i might have seen it in the
video store but i just never rented it
for whatever reason uh but then it just
kind of like disappeared for a really
long time but
it has been rediscovered and restored
and uh is part of severin's uh limited
edition box set but if you don't want to
pay the money i don't know how much that
is i'm assuming it's very expensive
because it comes with like a bunch of
stuff but uh you can actually watch this
on shutter at the moment you might be
able to like rent it other places too
because i'm assuming you know because
they just released it on blu-ray then
usually you can get it on streaming
services too i think you can get on roku
and stuff like that but i watched it on
shutter and uh it's definitely cool
definitely worth watching if you're into
folk horror um you know and so let me
know if you've seen it and if you've
seen it what you thought about it and
that will do it for this flickers of
fear our folk horror february continues
and i will see you guys on the next one
bye